c'est devenu un rituel tous les samedis
pendant une heure l'épicerie des
abeilles est ouverte
notre client il lui faut une salade la
proximité
les bons légumes
le pain voilà c'est nous évite de faire
quelques kilomètres pour pour aller
chercher les légumes moi je me suis dit
que dès l'instant quelqu'un fait quelque
chose dans le village je vois pas
pourquoi on viendrait pas c'est super
bien le boucher une fois par semaine le
fromager toutes les deux semaines
les commerces se font rares aviv hoc je
n'ai pas le permis donc toujours demandé
et c'est embêtant
vous voyez on me portent des affaires en
titre ou rouge livres directement à noël
sont formidables celle qu'elle s'occupe
un ca fait plaisir
l'épicerie fonctionne depuis le
confinement grâce à la mairie
aujourd'hui une association a repris le
flambeau fruits et légumes oeufs peints
elle ne propose que des produits locaux
et fonctionne sur commande
l'association affirme ne pas faire de
marge car l'intéressent d'entretenir le
lien social mise à mal par la crise
sanitaire
le coc vidéo lieu d'avoir cet esprit de
solidarité
personnellement je trouve que ça tous
les faits ne verse et que les gens
restent chez eux et deviennent très
individualiste et justement par ce biais
les gens se retrouvent et sont
demandeurs de
de cette action nous notre ambition
c'est vraiment d'aider les gens les
personnes de notre village et delà des
communes aux alentours pour les aider
dans leur dans leur course au quotidien
et de rabbi tuer les gens à manger des
produits locaux
l'épicerie des abeilles ne compte pas en
rester là elle veut par exemple proposer
des produits à base de chèvre chaque
semaine une vingtaine de clients de tout
âge s'approvisionnent dans ce commerce
associatif